my first time at the Emmys you're doing
the in memoriam section I'm sure it's
very moving what was it like doing
performing and rehearsing I had to kind
of keep my composure because just to be
a part of a segment like that and pay
tribute to all the people that we've
lost it was yeah it was very moving
was there any moment to kind of taught
you I tried not to look at the screen to
them that's where they're you know
showing everybody and so I did catch
Prince at the end and that kind of you
know I was like so I'll try it I'm going
to try to keep my composure and just
yeah just pay respect all right I hear
you're in the studio what are you
writing about and singing about in who
are you writing and singing about
everything I said with this album I've
been experimenting a lot lyrically I
think I'm kind of going into the past
with like just past relationships new
ones just rigid and not even just love
I've been talking about like just life
things that I observed just in our
culture and I've been just having fun
with it
you